you
you see someone you sort of like them or
don't like them before the word exchange
or something I have no idea what it is
but this body language or whatever I'm
arrogant your modesty so that's a major
purchase instinct but before I ever
interview the person and Mike K I'm
fortunate because I've had a large
number of applicants each year and so I
can kind of pick who I think of the best
people and even so one makes mistakes
not infrequently but you see what kind
of leverage were they trained in what
kind of letters recommendation they have
which journals they published in and
sometimes one will take a student who
didn't publish anything yet if the
letters are explaining why they didn't
than why this young person is very
promising and so on so the filtering
goes on first look reading the letter
getting letters of recommendation
looking at grade point averages or
publications depending what level of was
graduating they're postdocs and then the
chemistry when they come to the
laboratory if if you invite them to
laboratory there what's the chemist will
be doing that I owe some very fortunate
having some extremely talented young
people with me and I let them press the
calipers over these potential applicants
- we usually agree pretty much on who we
should offer position who should not